حيث تدفقت الحمم البركانية القاتلة على جبل
نيورالونجو
الآن غير ضار نسبيًا بعد أسبوع
من ثوران أحد أخطر البراكين في
العالم مع العلماء
بما في ذلك عالم البراكين الذي
درس الجبل منذ عام 1995.
يحتاجون إلى بضعة أيام أخرى لتحديد
ما إذا كان الخطر هو  ذهب
أنا لا أستبعد احتمال
ثوران بركان آخر
أفكر فيه وأقول أنه من الناحية
الإحصائية هناك فرص قليلة جدًا
لحدوث
هذا ، يقول تيديسكو ، إن الانفجار الأخير كان من
المستحيل توقع
بقاء السكان القريبين على حافة
الهاوية في مدينة غوما الكونغولية  ليس محاطًا
ببركان واحد ولكن اثنين من البراكين النشيطة gongo
و nyamiragira
أنا في فوهة البركان الثاني
يمكن أن يندلع أي من هؤلاء في أي وقت
مما يؤدي إلى الموت والدمار في
أعقابهم ، ولا يزال الألم الناتج عن الانفجار الأول
يحترق
تمامًا ويعود كافيرا إلى حيث
اعتاد أن يكون
منزلها.  ix أطفال وليس هناك
دخل
يسجل على الفور خسارتها مع
مسؤول محلي لكنها لا تعتقد أنها
ستحصل على أي مساعدة
للبدء من جديد
غرب غوما هذه الجوقة في
التدريبات من أجل خدمة الأحد
كالمعتاد ولكن الكنيسة مليئة بالفعل
بالتجمع الداخلي.
نازح
هم من بين 400000 فروا
دون مأوى لأولئك الذين تم إجلاؤهم ،
انتهى بهم الأمر في أي مكان تم الترحيب بهم فيه
حتى في الشرفات الأمامية للغرباء.
لذا
فمن الخطورة
وجود مرافق مراحيض
محدودة وليست صحية
ومن ثم نخشى أيضًا أن
يتم تغطيتنا لأننا لا نمتلك أقنعة حتى
بعد يوم من حديث CNN مع أغنيس ،
عادت إلى المنزل ضد نصيحة الحكومة التي
لم يفعلها الجميع  كان مكانًا للعودة إلى
العديد من منازل 900 التي
سوتها الانفجار البركاني
لبعض أفقر سكان هذا المجتمع.
كان أحدهم
جيرانهم ، كل ما تبقى الآن
هو جبل من الحمم البركانية منازلهم
مصنوعة من القصدير
أو الخشب ، لذلك كانوا
معرضين للخطر بشكل خاص وبدون تأمين أو
دعم حكومي ،
لن يتمكنوا أبدًا من إعادة البناء
حتى مع دورة من الكوارث الطبيعية
المرض وفرحة النزوح
والإيمان لا يبتعدان أبدًا في جمهورية الكونغو الديمقراطية
لاري ميدول سي إن غوما